so yeah as Marco said today I'm going to
be talking about some of our latest work
on architecting Next Generation
autonomous vehicle autonomy
stacks and here we're really focusing on
developing the next generation of Av
autonomy stacks and to understand why we
need a Next Generation let's talk a
little about what the classical
architecture for autonomy Stacks look
like so typically they look something
like this they're very highly modular
and you typically have key components
for you know detection tracking
prediction planning and control and this
is the typical structure that's taught
for example the students here or or
around at other universities and that
many AV companies adopt so some key
advantages here are that you can
interpret what these modules are
outputting you can develop them
independently however there are
information bottlenecks between each of
these components so you might have a
performance ceiling based on the
information that you can actually pass
from Upstream to
Downstream now on the other hand kind of
a recent advancement has also been
looking at endtoend architectures where
typically you're trying to connect
perception directly to control through
like a neural network or or a few neural
networks and you know you're only really
implicitly encoding key capabilities
like agent prediction or detection or
tracking now some key advantages are
that you might actually have a higher
performance ceiling because now there's
no information bottlenecks however you
also don't know if you can guarantee
safety because you typically can't
analyze you know are you detecting all
the objects are you able to track them
through time are you able to actually
safely avoid
them um now so you know there are some
difficulties about making formal safety
claims as compared to maybe modular
autonomy Stacks so given the current
state of things a natural question is
whether we can maybe design something
that takes the Best of Both Worlds
Without maybe having too much of the
detriment and in particular if we view
these architectures on a spectrum what
would something in the Middle look
like and so this is actually part of
what I'll talk about today which is I'll
going I'll be going over some of our
latest work on designing modular and
differentiable autonomy Stacks which
combine the reusability and
interpretability of the modular a stack
but also with the theoretical higher
performance ceiling of N2 Navy
architectures now the other necessary
innovation in order to actually develop
newer architectures like this is in the
surrounding infrastructure so in
particular I'll also talk later in the
talk about some of our latest work on
simulation leveraging data for better
behavior and I'll show some of our
really latest latest latest work that we
just submitted you know a couple weeks
ago uh in this direction as well so this
is actually exactly what I'll talk about
today so I'll first talk about about you
know some methods for how to expand the
flow of information between these uh uh
you know stacks and the the modules in
the autonomy stack I'll talk about how
we can optimize some components for
directly for Downstream performance
because of enabling modular
differentiability and then lastly I'll
talk about leveraging data for
simulation and some of our latest work
on you know generating realistic human
like
traffic so without further Ado I want to
focus the the first part here on talking
about how we can combine three typically
learned modules uh detection tracking
prediction to enable better
performance so typically when we want to
remove information bottlenecks in the AV
stack it very quickly becomes a question
of robustness because all of these you
know uh uh components produce
uncertainty or at least they're not
going to be perfect you're going to have
errors you're going to have something
that you need to take into account and
so there are many sources in the
uncertainty stack and the running
example I'm going to show show here
first is in detection where you might
have probabilities about what class and
object is or you might have uncertainty
about where it's located in the
image and I you know I guess it's it's
hard maybe to see if you're sitting here
but there's kind of a lot of these
probabilities they fluctuate and you
have these kind of classes that switch
over time but as you can imagine this
uncertainty is going to affect tracking
which is going to affect prediction
which is going to affect planning which
is going to affect how your vehicle
moves in the world and so all of this is
actually really interconnected whether
you want it to be or
not and so you know our group has done
quite a lot of work in trying to analyze
some of this uncertainty and explicitly
incorporate it in you know different
modules here in the stack but today in
particular I'm going to focus on this
connection between tracking and
prediction and I'm going to focus on how
we can make prediction models that are
robust to the kinds of errors that you
typically see in track tracking and in
particular I'll talk about the most
common kinds which are fragmentation and
ID switching and I'll show some examples
of what those look like so in this video
we can see what some of the tracking
errors look like in the wild where
basically an ID switch is kind of like
if you have two you know vehicles in the
real world that maybe come very close to
each other or they kind of one obscures
the other then your tracking system
might think ah okay these you know these
two vehicles they didn't just continue
straight past each other they you know
turned around and went like this because
again they look maybe the same they're
passing in front of each other they're
very close it's very easy to get
confused uh another kind of problem is
called fragmentation where you have
let's say again another vehicle passing
in front of the other and you say okay
the vehicle that was occluded it's now
not the same vehicle that you observe
later you just say you give it a new ID
because hey I see you know I saw one
vehicle then I didn't see anything and
then I saw another vehicle and so this
is typically called fragmentation so
these two problems are very common in
uh uh multiobject tracking and you know
it's not just that they're common in
tracking they're extraordinarily
detrimental in prediction because in
prediction you really rely on these
tracked trajectories to develop an
understanding of dynamics of motion of
these objects so to to give an
illustration here on the top left we
have an object that was tracked
perfectly you know it's a car that's
turning left and we can see that the
resulting yellow predictions you know
they're more or less reasonable right
they're continuing towards the left
they're kind of staying on the road I
know it's tough to see that this is a
road here cuz I'm kind of visualizing
the liar outputs but that's that's my
bad but you can see that the you know
predictions look
reasonable when we have a tracking error
here and we have an ID switch you can
see that now we have let's say like a
false positive detection that causes
your bounding you know your tracker to
think ah this vehicle now moved up
Suddenly it has like a you know an
errant acceleration and as you can see
the predictions are now off the screen
screen right they're they're
useless and actually when you evaluate
this quantitatively over like an
autonomous driving data set you can see
that these kinds of tracking errors they
significantly increase the uh presence
of prediction errors and they can really
make your you know your lovely predictor
that you train on ground tro data use
completely unusable in the real world
with with errors that are so
high so to remedy
this uh what we asked in the group was
okay the hard part here is that tracking
typically needs to make a hard decision
of which detection is mapped to which
previous track and the question we had
was okay this hard you know choice
really loses a lot of data because there
could be a lot of uncertainty that you
just have to say okay if it's 51% 49% I
just have to take the 51% and you're
neglecting all of this uncertainty so we
asked okay can we remove these hard
associations that need to be made and
can we instead pass all of this
information
to your Downstream predictor which I
here draw as like a Transformer based
model so this is actually the exact idea
that we evaluated and rather than just
directly taking you know all the
previous detections we took the previous
detections as well as their similarities
over time so when I say here similarity
I mean for example visual similarity or
the the how close they are in you know
frame by frame in space and these you
know how similar an object is from frame
to frame we call that Affinity this is a
term that you might hear in computer
vision a lot and so we take this
Affinity information as well and
directly encode uh directly uh uh
structure it inside the Transformer's
attention where we're trying to attend
you know one time step like one set of
objects in one frame to sets of objects
in previous
frames and when we take this soft
information now rather than making a
hard choice we can actually reduce the
presence of prediction errors in these
cases where there are tracking Errors By
what is it up to 80% here so now finally
we can actually start to harness some of
this uncertainty and not get you know
you know demolished when we have these
errors and to show an example of what
this looks like on the left here I have
the standard pipeline where you have a
decomposed system of tracking and then
prediction and what you can see is you
see these are all parked cars here but
you can see that when there's like this
errant you know associations there's
like predictions that are being made for
these parked vehicles to move which is
you know problematic if you're going to
try pass next to them whereas on the
right with these same you know detection
errors we don't have any of these same
predictions being made we don't have any
of these errant predictions for parked
cars so when you say you changed it from
a hard decision to a soft decision
essentially what you did is you had the
model like implicitly figure out how to
track exactly correct that's exactly
correct Y in case the question wasn't
heard um by switching from hard decision
to soft decision it's basically tasking
the model with doing tracking implicitly
under the
hood perfect so moving on looking a
little bit more
Downstream the next thing that we wanted
to look at was so okay maybe this wasn't
so surprising right because at least
detection tracking and prediction a lot
of those are learned components so it's
actually very easy to connect things
without maybe losing too much
information I know tracking wasn't
learned here but we you know found a
nice way to kind of bypass it and have
the model implicitly encoded what about
when we look Downstream at prediction
planning and control which typically
have a mixture of learning based
components and handcrafted components
and traditionally here prediction for
example is typically a neural network so
uh you know I'm going to go with a
running example of a some specific
prediction network but typically it's
learning based and then we have a
planner and a controller which are
typically handcrafted hand designed hand
engineered for you know let's say the
specific vehicle that you want to
control or or the specific design domain
that you have in mind and so the
question here is how can we actually
combine these and maybe enable
differentiability throughout all these
modules so that the actual final goal of
driving behavior can influence how the
prediction model
learns so in a traditional system
typically the only uh component that's
learned is your prediction model and
your prediction model is tasked with you
know estimating what will happen in the
future for all the agents around you and
then you use that information in a
planner so in this running example the
planner that we use is a very simple
sampling based planner you sample some
amount of candidates and then you
evaluate them using a cost function
taking into account your predictions so
you know you could say Okay I want to
sample the one that has the lowest
chance of colliding as an example and
then you'll take that best the lowest
cost plan you'll pass that into a
control controller it'll apply a little
bit of dynamic smoothing and then you
can just drive on it so this is like a
very simple but typical planning uh
prediction plan and control stack what
we wanted to look at in this work was
making those two end components
differentiable and in particular the way
that we did this was for the controller
we used prior work there exists quite a
lot of work on making NPC and other
algorith other optimization algorithms
like it
differentiable and then we also made
that simple sampling based planning
algorithm differentiable by switching it
from you know rank just ranking these
kind of sample trajectories by a cost
function and we changed it to more like
a classification algorithm where you
still have these sample trajectories but
now you have a model that's kind of
classifying which of these is most
likely to be the best because then at
least now you have that
differentiability in mind rather than
having to pick like an argmax or an
argmin I guess in this case which is
non- differentiable for planning
and so the key thing here like I said
the key thing here connecting us back to
our original goal was to enable
Downstream task losses and gradients to
propagate all the way through these
modules and inform how we train our
prediction module or at least prediction
and maybe anything upstream and so the
way that you know we trained our our
model was basically we have you know
data set that we're using like you know
some public open source autonomous
vehicle data set and what we do is we
add costs for each of these components
to train them like you know we need to
train that uh uh classification module
in the planner uh we don't have to train
anything in the controller but we at
least can evaluate the overall
performance of the output trajectory by
compare Computing like a hindsight cost
so hindsight cost here basically means
how different is the control that you
enacted compared to if you had perfect
knowledge of the world so at least you
you have a sense of maybe what the best
possible performance is compared to what
you did and that's kind of what we use
as like Downstream final performance
measurements and then basically you know
we trained these different components
and then so we kind of trained each of
them separately and then we had the a
final round of passing all the gradients
through and training each of the mod
modules Al
together and what we found was that
compared to the traditional stack where
you have the decomposed
system what's funny is actually the
prediction performance was more or less
the same so in terms of like the actual
if you just measure the prediction
output you know nothing really
changed but the planning performance
significantly improved and what this
basically means and so here the the
hindsight reward is basically how close
are you to Optimal So to that perfect
trajectory if you had perfect
information so here the plan with our
differentiable stack was 80 3% of the
reward of the you know this perfect plan
or at least the all knowing plan and
whereas the other standard module St was
only 71% of the way there and so what
you're able to see here is that although
the kind of average accuracy of the
predictor didn't change at all where it
made errors did change so now what we
were able to do is basically learn a
prediction module that was more useful
for planning so rather than just making
kind of uniformly distributed errors all
across the scene it learned for example
to care a little bit less about objects
that are 80 M away or a little bit less
about objects that are you know turning
completely away from us that will never
be able to you know you know turn back
and influence the ego vehicle's uh
behavior um I see a question back
there how do you know was where the CH
that's the reason why you planning could
it also be just that the planner like
like the calibration between the
predictions and the planner they kind of
match because you're training both of
them in parallel yeah it's a good
question so uh the first thing is we
visualize we have like visualization so
that helps but actually the second thing
you said is is also an important point
maybe the calibration is better like
maybe the uncertainties are better I
don't have numbers for you so I don't
have like a I can say one thing
definitively but at least to towards you
know such an approach like this I think
that's only a benefit if you can
actually align the output of uncertainty
with the use of uncertainty
[Music]
um yeah thank you for the question
um are there any other questions before
I move on to the topic of evaluation and
simulation perfect so the final broad
topic that I'll discuss is you know
let's say that we have a a fantastic
stack and you know it's differentiable
and modular and whatever it's perfect
and we're really happy how can we
actually be certain that this thing is
really as good as we think it is before
we actually want to deploy it in the
real world where it kind of matters how
good your plans
are so you
know simulation is in many ways the Holy
Grail to scaling up the verification and
validation of autonomy
stacks and you know indeed in the past
few decades we've seen there the
autonomous vehicle research Community
has made tremendous progress in
developing tons of simulators
with you know very strong I mean earlier
on it was very strong Dynamic and
kinematic modeling performance but now
we have simulators that can you know
photo realistically render an
environment and really so you can now
even test your perception stack as well
in the
mix um however even with all these
fantastic
simulators it's still difficult to
actually just directly apply them to the
task that we have at hand of you know
really fully evaluating an autonomy
stack and that's because arguably the
key missing piece is that the behaviors
of other simulated agents such as cars
and and pedestrians and urban
environments are still controlled by
very simple logic or or very simple you
know differentiable uh what's it called
um differential equation type model like
State space models but unfortunately
real world driving behaviors are much
more complex than these simple models
and so to truly create a realistic
driving simul where you can actually
harness all of these you know photo
realistic elements we need to build
intelligent agents as well so that we
can generate realistic humanik driving
behaviors around the ego
vehicle so concretely we've identified
here four key deserada for simulation uh
for traffic models to be useful for
simulation so the first is probably
obviously Fidelity which is you know can
we actually synthesize agent behaviors
that are realistic and faithful to how
humans Drive in the real
world diversity can we generate a wide
range of realistic traffic behaviors
because it's not just you know if you're
at an intersection there's not just one
way that traffic could move through that
intersection or through the you know
whatever environment there's multiple
possible ways that are you know more or
less equally
likely the third is controllability so
we don't just want to generate tons of
very you know varying types of scenarios
we want to actually steer these
simulations to the kinds of scenarios we
care about maybe we want to specifically
evaluate a left turn or an unpredicted
left turn or some kind of strange right
turn scenario with like you know weird
Road uh Dynamics uh weird Road geometry
so we actually need to be able to also
steer these models to give us behaviors
that we're particularly looking
for and then lastly is a bit more of a
longer a broader goal of adaptivity so
typically a lot of the models that we'll
be training to do you know to generate
realistic behaviors we'll be training
them from specific data sets that were
captured in you know take your pick of
cities in the US or around the world the
problem is you know the whole promise of
simulation is that we can simulate
anything or theoretically we want to
simulate anything and so if I have a
model that's trained in data from Boston
New York City Singapore or whatever what
happens when I move it now to San
Francisco or Seattle or Toronto or
whatever right we need to be able to
actually adapt these models to new
regions and hopefully without having to
collect a ton of data or do a ton of
hand engineered fine tuning because
that's not really
scal um now along the way we'll talk
about some of the challenges that you
run into and maybe some ways to solve
them but the first typical challenge is
stability so how do you actually prevent
your simulation from leaving you know
nice smooth driving behaviors um and
this typically happens when you have
longer Horizon simulations where maybe
you've trained your models to only you
know predict motion for I don't know
know at most 5 or 10 seconds but now
you're simulating for potentially a
minute or longer you know if some
scenario is
needed so you know we'll talk about some
of these challenges as we get to them um
but I want to start and also
unfortunately for um due to lack of time
I won't talk about ad adaptivity today
but we do have work on this so by all
means check out some of the links I'll
put up at the end and and you'll see
some of our work
there now as I've shown in some of the
previous slides we definitely have the
capability to model human behavior
because we're learning it in the car to
predict the motion of other vehicles so
why don't we just try and use some of
these already quite strong and quite
accurate uh Behavior models in order to
simulate agents um for us so the
question here is can we just can we just
do this and problem solved and you know
we're we're all really
happy unfortunately no and I'll show an
example of what that looks like so on
the left here I just have a normal
driving trajectory that's taken from
just logged data so this is very smooth
driving motion you know as you can see
cars are just typically sticking to the
Lane and the the orange car here is is
like you know the agent that's being
modeled let's say so this is ground Tru
data if I just take out even a
state-of-the-art prediction model and I
apply to control this vehicle in an auto
regressive fashion by making some
predictions driving for a bit feeding
that new uh data back in and and
repeated doing this as you can see very
quickly this prediction model gets out
of you
know you know it gets out of normal
driving behavior and we're it's
basically useless right it's just
stopping here in the middle of the road
and the fundamental reason behind this
kind of Divergence from good behavior
lies in the fact that prediction model
errors accumulate over time and when
they accumulate enough now your neural
network is kind of outside of the
training data distribution that it was
originally trained for and now and
neural networks have quite a difficult
time even with all the you know amazing
methods that have been developed since
it's that's still a very difficult
problem and so you know unfortunately
you make a bit of error at the first
time step then you feed that back into
the model make an error on the next time
step and then it just grows and you know
it's hopeless as you've seen so the
first of our works in this direction was
actually targeted to tackling this
problem so the way that we tackled this
problem is that we decomposed the
problem
of behavior modeling for simulation into
two sub problems the first is um
predicting where the agent wants to go
and then once we have kind of like a
goal point in mind the second sub
problem is basically connecting a to B
and having the you know connecting where
the agent is currently to where it wants
to go through this inferred goal and the
video I'm showing here which I'll play
again so what you can see here on the
right is that first level of the
hierarchy where we're estimating the
goal of where the agent wants to go
using this kind of spatial probability
heat map over the scene and then on the
left you can see the resulting like the
the you know the trajectory that
connects the to but you can also see
that even when we're repeatedly running
this we actually have very stable
driving behavior that you can actually
just run you know for a while
and most importantly this modeling of
this agent happens it's like every agent
is modeled independently and what's good
about this is every agent actually can
think for itself and it has kind of like
a like an observation neighborhood
around itself as well so you can
actually get very complicated behaviors
even from a simple model like this which
is just kind of you know estimating a
very likely place for this agent to go
without really much prior
information and even better because this
model that we've developed um
specifically it's called
bits this model that we developed also
has stochasticity inside it so we can
actually even from the exact same
initialization of the scenario we can
generate diverse roll outs for you know
even the exact same
map and this is a really good thing
because it enables counterfactual
reasoning or also known as what if
reasoning now I've shown you some nice
you know gifs here but that's you know
all of that's really nice but is it
actually you know how can we actually
evaluate that these trajectories are
indeed good and this is quite a
difficult question because it's very
difficult to evaluate behavioral realism
especially when you don't have an
Associated ground truth trajectory that
you can compare to remember the whole
point of simulation is that I want to
generate new and diverse and not you
know realistic but not necessarily seen
before trajectories and so you can't
really compare that to you know know
just ground TR data that you
collected and so the way that we tackled
this problem in this paper and in some
of our follow on uh simulation works is
to basically come up with a concert of
metrics that kind of help you pinpoint
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
different simulation approaches and
there's kind of three different High uh
three different levels to these metrics
so the first is analyzing the specific
trajectory level like trajectory level
information that is output by your
simulation model so here what you can
look at is for example over repeated
simulations how much area is covered by
your motion how diverse are the
trajectories that are generated per roll
out and what are the failure rates so
here I mean for example Collision rate
or or driving off-road so at least we
have some semblance of like you know uh
following
rules the second level is that you can
look you can kind of step back a little
bit and look at statistical differences
to real world data so so maybe I can't
compare exactly on a trajectory per
trajectory basis but what I can do is I
can compare kind of the General
Distribution of some of the dynamic
quantities that were output by the model
so I can look for example at the
difference in the histogram of speed or
jerk or acceleration or whatever else
quantity that you care about and compare
that to real world collected data
sets and then lastly and this is
probably a little bit in the researchy
space is maybe I can try and learn a
separate model
that's just focused on devising a
measure of human likeness or human
likelihood of the kinds of you know
trajectories that you're generating it's
a bit weird though because you're using
one model to evaluate the other so I'm
going to say definitely still more work
needs to be done on this space but there
are some ideas here and you'll see some
you know research works that are doing
this now I already so far talked about
Fidelity and and um diversity the third
is it
was controlability
so one thing you know is it's one thing
to generate nice behaviors but the other
thing is how can we actually generate
the specific behaviors that we care
about and so the first approach that we
did here was to first of all change kind
of the way that we're generating
trajectories so before we had this
hierarchical distribution so here we
still have like a this hierarchical idea
but it's now being done by a diffusion
model what's nice about the diffusion
model is that it has this internal
process of denoising and what is it
called yeah diffusion and why this is
nice is because we can actually inject
some guidance into that process in order
to generate the kinds of motions that we
care about and the way that we chose to
do this for this work is we chose to
allow the user to specify formal Logic
for how they want a scene to evolve and
the language that we use for this is STL
or signal temper logic so basically
users can come up to this uh simulator
specify okay I want all vehicles to not
Collide I want this vehicle to be at
this position at this velocity I want
you know in this kind of formal language
and then we can use the resulting
robustness formulas that this STL you
know framework generates and use that to
guide the generation process of this
model and what this allows us to do is
exactly you know so here's an example of
you know say we wanted some vehicles to
stop in specific places I'm visualizing
here some of these trajectories but
basically what you can see is that in
the top I give no guidance right these
vehicles are just moving through an
intersection with some nominal speed but
in the bottom when we ask them to stop
at a specific point you could see that
they started slowing down much earlier
on to so that they kind of perfectly end
up in that
place now I also understand that you
know from a user perspective you know
maybe not everyone is like a
mathematician and knows how to specify
STL formulas it's not really that user
friendly so something that we then
subsequently worked on was how to make
that interface a little bit more natural
and here we turn to language and this
was especially you know important as now
we actually have such models that can
interpret language and in in our case
what we did was we you know took like a
users language specification for how
they wanted a scene to
evolve use a large language model to
then output for us the kinds of logical
formula that guide the scene generation
and then as per normal as per before we
use that guidance to generate a uh
simulation and the good thing is this
doesn't just have to come from user you
know you typing yourself it actually
unlocks an entire new area of data that
can be used that otherwise was not able
to be used for and that's primarily
textual data like police reports
insurance reports crash reports from you
know governmental agencies which we can
now
reconstruct and then use to simulate uh
these kinds of very rare scenarios and
I'll show you some examples of this so
for this particular case where you know
I want to generate a vehicle that
crashes into another one at a very
specific you know a very specific way I
wanted to crash on the left side or or
something like that you can see that
when we pass this in it's actually able
to do this you know just like that and
towards the point I was making earlier
we can take in some uh uh real world
Collision reports like from the you know
the these ones are from the National
Highway Traffic Safety Authority
Transportation safety Authority
something like that and we're able to
actually reconstruct them here and use
them as you know simulation environments
which we can then uh uh put our own
vehicle in for
example even nicer is that you know
these language models they have so much
inherent
domain understanding of natural language
input that even if we never you know
even if a lot of you know our original
you know training regime never had the
words like sparse or crowded or whatever
we able to use these kinds of modifiers
and actually have output that matches
what the user wants here in terms of
like sparsity for
traffic or you know beyond just
generating a scene like onetime initial
scene generation Our method also enables
editing and already generated so let's
say you do have a scene that was
generated but there's one or two things
wrong with it and you want to change
that so here you can actually
continually make updates by specifying
okay make this car do this make this car
do this make this car do this and one
thing that I want to point out here on
the very
right when we gave it the prompt to
speed up cars that are moving in the
same direction in particular here same
direction with respect to this red
vehicle what you can see is compared to
this one it had to move the blue vehicle
to the right because otherwise these
vehicles are turning left which means
that they're naturally going to be going
slower than someone who's just going
straight through and so it actually
moved this blue vehicle over it has
enough domain understanding of driving
to move that blue vehicle over to then
enable it to actually speed up through
that intersection which was you know
quite interesting to see from our
perspective now all of this is great but
everything I showed is still at the
traffic simulation level so this is
great for testing a prediction planning
control but remember to fully eval an a
stack we also have perception and
everything that happens
upstream and so recently you know when
you need to handle when you need to
model the world from a and actually
perceive it this is where you start
entering the problems of dynamic scene
representation and dynamic scene
reconstruction and so in particular
there's been a lot of recent work using
neural Radiance fields or Nerfs maybe
some of you have heard this term to
reconstruct kind of collect you know
environments that an autonomous vehicle
has already passed through and already
collected some data from um in order to
you know reconstruct the a very
realistic looking uh uh um uh like data
capture of this and Nerf is able to
represent that and then allow you to re
simulate you know what your sensors
would have seen if you placed your you
know car at a specific point and you you
had a specific view Direction or
something like
that now a lot of these methods the way
that they work and and maybe you'll
notice in these videos there's no moving
Vehicles anywhere in this video and
that's because Nerf methods typically
struggle to handle Dynamic objects
because they break a lot of the multiv
view consistency assumptions that you
make within Nerf and so what methods
typically do is they'll have like a
they'll have like a like an initial
masking step or maybe they'll use uh
ground truth annotations or maybe
they'll use a pre-trained model for
object detection to detect cars
pedestrians bicyclist whatever get their
bounding boxes and then remove those
kind of subtract those from the scene
and actually you can see this here if
you have good eyes you see these black
splotches here on the left those are
parked cars that were removed but they
didn't remove their Shadows I mean
difficult thing to do but so you can see
right they do this first step then they
regenerate the static world and I mean
hey it looks beautiful but you are
missing this Dynamic
element
so can we leverage this High Fidelity
representation capability of Nerf but
still represent Dynamic objects because
obviously for driving this is extremely
important and more importantly can we do
this without requiring ground trth
annotation or using some pre-trained you
know bounding box detection model which
might have some you know errors or
something like
that
absolutely right otherwise I wouldn't be
asking these
questions and I'm going to show you
first some of the results and then I'll
talk about about the method but what you
can see here so each of these in each of
these
videos this method that I'll talk about
in the next uh slide is able to purely
from self-supervision decompose the
static and dynamic components of a scene
so what you're looking at here on the
top and I'll talk about what these
colors are later but what you're looking
at on the top is basically anything that
just has a normal RGB color from the
sensor this is static this has been
decomposed by our method to be static
non-changing throughout the entire scene
and then everything that has this you
know funky colors is some Dynamic you
know element so we can see that here
pedestrians are highlighted vehicles are
highlighted and and and all that as they
as they pass through same thing at the
bottom here we can see a similar thing
where you know I'm just showing you the
dynamic elements of the scene without
any static El like all the static
elements were
removed so the way that we do this while
still using like a a neural field based
approach is we prot and this is the
title actually of the paper which will
soon be online so give give it a few
days um the way that we do this is we
decompose every scene into three
separate components the first is a
static field so this is kind of like a
traditional Nerf right I'm just modeling
the static world without any Dynamic uh
objects in there the second is a dynamic
field so whereas the first field just
takes in the XYZ position of your camera
and the view Direction the dynamic field
it's 4D so it takes in the XYZ and the
time because it matters you know where
this these vehicles are in time as well
as the view
Direction but now that's just having
these two is not good enough and
actually I'll show you you guys might
have noticed the difference between
these two
videos you see in the bottom one when
the car is moving it'll replay again
when you you see when the car is moving
at the beginning do you see a lot of
this artifacts around the edge if you
just do a static and dynamic field this
is what you get where when the car is
moving I mean sensibly everything in the
world is moving relative to the car and
so you get this these artifact and then
when everything's stationary
everything's looking great this is an
earlier result compared to this
result to really sharpen up this Dynamic
understanding this is where we also
introduce a flow field this is also a 4D
field but the whole point of the four
flow field is to connect the individual
Dynamic field objects in time
and so what the flow field is test with
doing is calculating okay if we do have
elements in the dynamic field what flow
or what like Delta should I add to them
so that I know where they'll be in the
next time step and what you can do is
you can use this flow field to associate
your Dynamic components in time and this
yields a very strong learning signal
because now you can aggregate uh what's
it called you can aggregate features
over time but it also it's also mutually
reinforcing so static dynamic
decomposition is improved by also trying
to learn flow and then flow is also
improved by having a better Dynamic
field and Etc so actually during
learning both of these are really uh uh
improving the performance of the
other and what this allows you to do
is so I have here some of kind of the
outputs of when you use this full model
so on the top is just the ground truth
image that was passed in like by the
sensors here is the rendered thing so
from your perspective there's going to
be no difference you have to like zoom
in very very deep to see differences and
then here I want to point out in this
third row we can see the decomposed
static RGB so you see this car here gone
with no Shadow Remnant left behind
because that shadow we have like a you
know first of all we have a special head
for capturing that but also that kind of
stuff is captured in the flow field so
those kinds of remnants which otherwise
you would get if you just tried to
naively remove it are actually now just
naturally handled by the model same
thing on this side do you see all these
pedestrians gone as if it was done by
you know
Photoshop and here's the dynamic like
the if you just want to you know parse
out just the dynamic object you can see
what that looks like here and here's the
flow I mean this hard to interpret but
it's basically showing you the the the
speeds of things moving in the
scene now the final thing that's very
impressive about this model so not only
are we trying to reconstruct you know
the RGB and depth and then this Dynamic
static stuff we can also add additional
features here and what's quite
interesting here and you know some
parallel lines of work that you might be
aware of are there are some very
powerful visual Foundation models
nowaday which are also trained from
self-supervision but they learn these
very strong semantic features so I'm
going to I'm showing here an example of
Dino V2 which was released by meta I
don't know how many months ago I forget
now but these kinds of features you can
also try and and train this model that I
showed in the last slide to
reconstruct and what this allows you to
do is generates well one some very wacky
colors but two what I'm visualizing here
is those reconstructed semantic features
pass through PCA just so that we can
actually have some colors here and
remember this is all I haven't there's
no labeling here or anything like that
so just by using these pre-trained
features from another model which exists
for free we can color buildings or like
we can identify that buildings are
buildings they're all the same color we
can see all vehicles here all the same
color all static Vehicles here all the
same color and I'm showing here you know
in RGB I'm I'm like decomposing you know
the dynamic static at least so you can
see but what's really nice about this is
that now that this method that we
developed originally for simulation you
can now actually use this for auto
labeling because once you have a car
passed through an
environment you can you know with our
approach decompose it into Dynamic
static remove the dynamic Parts if you
want reconstruct these you know very uh
important semantic features and now you
can label the map the buildings the the
whatever right just like this without
human labeling without you know tons of
models behind the
mix so I know that was a lot to take in
but stepping back a little bit I want to
say in general Now is really a fantastic
time for AV research I know a lot of
people say ah but you know wh was
driving around an SF yes there's so many
problems though that still need to be
solved in order to really get us from
you know 90% performance to to 99.9999
Performance and one thing that's been
really helpful in you know accelerating
this kind of research in the space is
that there's been a significant amount
of data that's been open sourced ever
since about 2019 or so there's been
thousands of hours of data now that
researchers have access to and you know
it's not just from you know one city or
this other city or even from just the
Western Hemisphere right we have data
from all around the
world the only downside is that all of
this data is kind of in a unique format
so at least when I remember doing this
research it was really annoying to okay
I want to train something on new scenes
and then test it okay now I have to
spend two and a half weeks to switch my
codebase over entirely to a different
data set and then do the exact same
thing and then hey presso I have you
know a paper with two evaluations or
whatever so to make life a little bit
easier something we've also been working
on in the group is to develop a unified
API for loading multiple data sets
trajectory data and you know at least
from our perspective this has been so at
least for us foundational before we can
even start to do a lot of other
interesting research you have to kind of
build this data Foundation has been
simplifying our lives and I know you
know the reason I bring it up is because
we've open sourced it you know it has a
very open license Apache 2.0 and all
this this so if you're ever doing any
research like this and you think
something like this would be helpful by
all means check it out feel free to you
know ask questions uh on GitHub or just
email me if you have uh any
questions and also on the simulation
side as you can imagine there's a ton of
behind the scenes work that has to go
into actually making this all work and
so we've also uh released our simulation
framework for you know which has that
model bits and the other model we're
we're soon going to release that other
the um the language ones we're soon
going to be releasing them also in this
similar uh framework so if you're
interested in this kind of research by
all means take a look maybe it helps
you so some key takeaways here before I
conclude is I guess to conclude some key
takeaways
are whenever autonomy stack components
are being designed researched Etc just
keep in mind that you're never
evaluating just one block they impact
Downstream components they follow other
components there are uncertainties there
are other things to take into account so
just you know make sure to keep that in
mind and actually from a research
perspective revisiting the interfaces
between modules is likely actually to
yield more improvements more
advancements rather than just focusing
on modules
themselves also there's a full spectrum
of architectures between classical
modular approaches and endtoend
approaches I mean we showed one example
here where we have a differentiable
modular approach but keep in mind you
know there's a lot of other things that
can be done so whenever you're
developing these kinds of things in your
robotics uh research or coursework keep
the idea of differentiability and task
awareness in mind and I think you'll
find it can be surprisingly
helpful and lastly close loop simulation
is really you know the key enabling
capability for really vastly scaling up
the um verification and validation of
autonomous vehicle
stacks and you know
I think really data driven human uh and
environment modeling is really the key
that we need in order it's kind of the
key final piece that we need in order to
really scale up and use the simulation
for um evaluation
use so with that I want to thank you all
for your attention please you know if
you have any questions or you want to
see any of these papers take a look here
we're hiring so yeah thank you all for
your time
[Applause]
again
thank you Boris I think we had time for
one quick question but then we can uh of
course interact the speaker outside
where we have fza so who is the lucky
person to ask the
question go ahead um so in the uh model
previously what about objects that
transition from static to dynamic or
dynamic yeah great question so the good
thing about this work is that what we do
is we first take all the data from the
entire traversal of a scene so like
after a car has already moved through
and because we have this flow field if
there was an object that let's say was
like Dynamic let's say towards the end
of the scene that information makes its
way back so I wonder if I
have I have other videos I guess it's
not this one but I have other videos
where there is a parked car that starts
moving and it's always highlighted
because it brought that information back
as well from from the future as well
when it was doing this optimization
so we had trouble with it earlier on in
the project but this flow field really
helped crisp up um uh some of that
annoyance as well it's a good
question and you can even see here oh
sorry sorry Marco you could see here
because they're they're all stopped like
the pedestrians are all just standing
still so yeah yeah yeah it's
there all right so I think unfortunately
we had to wrap up but as I said we're
going to have pizza outside so take that
is an opport to ask C
my thank
you